and tonight we get to look at the
southpaw
stephen bronk gets the ball for the
bucks tonight
it is lane thomas who's been on base
11 straight games one hopper gold tucker
and dropped by tsutsugo did it bounce or
was it just dropped
retreated a little bit reset through it
and yeah just a little bit of a pick
but that's one uh
you're going to see picked at least nine
out of 10 times
brault's one two and swinging a miss
struck him out with a good slider he
doesn't strike out all that much for a
guy with that kind of power that's two
outs
first baseman number 19
josh bell
just a class act
total pro second round pick of the
pirates 2011 parts of five years with
the bucks
and a four pitch walk following
quick work puts two aboard
here's newman on the right side playing
second base tonight he throws out
yadiel hernandez
and here we go second time around for
the new net lefty josh rogers
upstairs with a breaking ball runner was
on the move but it matters not the
innings over
rogers strikeout number one one out
riley adams 250 hitting catcher a couple
of home runs
line to left coming on alford all boy
all the way to the wall
reynolds now trying to race to retrieve
it this will score a run
and instead of a single
it will be a triple as alford
has that ball skipped past him all the
way to the wall one nothing if you're
going to go and try to make this attempt
and come in and and make this diving
play you've got to try to stay under the
ball somehow some way you want to try to
keep it from getting by you go back to
the top of the order now for lane thomas
thomas rips one to left
and the nats lead two nothing
that will count as another
game on base 12 in a row
his 13th rbi is in that 14th overall
this year
get some oxygen before he gets back
behind the plate look at that little
cutter stays on it 108 mile an hour
knock stay hot lane thomas
lately they've been making better
contact against his fastball
oh now gamble
dives to make the catch
we go to the third inning and the
pirates will make a pitching change here
as i don't know if uh
they had a prescribed shortened start
for brault or not but he's out after two
innings and cody ponce
the right-handed reliever for the
pirates
it's the one to the soto
right there strike three call
nicely done by cody pogba the exact same
pitch
and soto again is arguing about it
that's a ball you can hear him say
tony randazzo this is a strike
he's still giving him it's a strike
probably letting soto vent a little bit
that's have to be a bit cranky again the
late night got in early this morning
cole tucker will lead it off for the
pirates
and into left center field and
yeah
drops past the left fielder hernandez
and so tucker with a dive and a
double it looks like a little first
pitch change up off the end of the bat
out there and left center just
out of the reach of the left
fielder hernandez is quite not long
enough about a foot short
fly ball to center
tucker has excellent speed lane thomas
sets up for a throw good arm yes he does
very strong but cole tucker will score
as the ball
was not even
handled cleanly by adams sacrifice fly
for hayes it's a 2-1 ball game
another south ball at howard howard
picked up the win
on tuesday against the tigers
oh
stumbles fumbles but guess wow
how about that
what's he missed didn't look like any
chance together oh what an adjustment
right there after the bobble like i
thought the same as you i mean this
could end in disaster and maybe there's
not even
worthy of a throw
and not only does he throw it i mean he
takes his time and throws
suzugo a perfect strike
that's great yeah a great recovery
here's josh bell batting right handed
fastball up there it goes
see you
later back to the bullpen
welcome back to pittsburgh
3-1 nationals
familiar batters box familiar batting
eye familiar ballpark and josh bell
doing what we just showed you he did
a bunch of times at pnc going deep
two on one out for alfred he's got a ton
of sock in that bat
there's a fly ball deep to right field
by alford and clear the deck
cannonball coming the other way over the
clemente bridge
it's his fifth
and it's 3-2
to straight away right field a no
doubter
fastball out over
here's the pitch and it's way up high he
walked him on four pitches with second
and third two outs
ramirez is going to get out of this
that's big
so it's still a one-run deficit nick
mears battles through that eighth here's
patrick murphy he's never had a safe
situation
in the big leagues
and a ground ball base hit for alford to
start
the bottom of the night the nationals by
the way have been walked off nine times
this season only the marlins and metz
have been walked off more times
[Applause]
oh gamble showed bunt and
it skips back toward the backstop
a wild pitch 3-0
and he's on a four-pitch walk
we're talking about a taxed bullpen
they're seeing signs of it right here
here's the set there's the bunt pulls it
back and skips away from adams and the
runners will advance that way
[Applause]
ground ball ties it
unbelievable that is unbelievable they
just conceded
the tying run 3-3
the nationals play back
in the bottom of the ninth
and it's tied and now hayes is one for
three tonight in his young career one
rbi in the ninth inning or later
2-1 base head ball game
key brian hayes raises the jolly roger
his first career walk-off
pirates come back
4-3 buckos on a friday night